now 30 years later it's being reimagined
as a tv show now like the movie original
the series is inspired by the real
all-american girls professional baseball
team that leak was started back in 1943
when many men were away fighting in
world war ii and it went on for 11 years
the series stars abby jacobson is carson
shaw she's a catcher in the league now
you of course know abby jacobson from
the hilarious tv show broad city in this
scene her character is stepping up to
the plate at tryouts for the league's
first season here's abby in action these
girls are really good
why are you watching what everyone else
is doing
watch yourself
yeah watch yourself
no you guys are right
i need that kind of confidence
[Music]
i guess it's just the lucky one
yeah okay lucky one abby jacobson is
also a co-creator executive producer and
writer for the show also stars in the
show good morning to you ms badass how
are you today
but before you say anything tony you saw
this swing tony is our professional
basketball baseball baseball yes i'm the
uh professional it's a great
swing yeah i mean i remember what i was
saying earlier like when we saw john
goodman play babe ruth he would really
pull off the swing you're pulling off
this yeah well done
looks good my dad will be so happy
but here you are abby you're a
co-creator you're a writer you're
starring in the show you already know
that people know this story very well
did you feel intimidated or pressured or
scared um yes very much so it's a lot of
people's favorite film yeah it's a
classic it's a classic yeah and it just
celebrated its third 30th anniversary
like like two weeks ago or something
like that so there's a lot of pressure
it's also one of my favorite films and
that's why i was so excited will graham
who i co-created it with asked me to do
this with him in 2017. wow i've been
working on this a long time and
from the beginning from the early
conversations it was never about
remaking
this film this is like it was never
going to be a remake it's not a remake
so like everyone's favorite film will be
right there watch whenever they want
this is a reimagining
so but are we going to hear the line
there's no crying in baseball
but it'll be coming from someone very
different
and will be contextually very different
but um yeah i think the spirit of the
film is definitely infused in the show
as much as we could but you know this
was made in 1992. it's a two-hour long
thing we have a lot more real estate and
we really wanted to focus on a lot of
the stories that they hinted at penny
marshall was able to allude to some
things and we really wanted to tell
a lot more of the stories
about a generation of women playing
baseball not just the ones that you see
in the film and speaking of some of
those stories you guys also touch on the
segregation and integration of the game
one of the players max is based on women
of color in that time why was it
important to have that layer within this
yeah so if you remember in the phone
there's an iconic scene there's a foul
ball a black woman picks it up and
chucks a heater throws a heater and then
it's sort of just like
there's no words it's just like wow
she's so good
and it said a lot but it didn't say it a
lot but it does not
it doesn't pull it out at all
we
fully pull it out
and so it's a huge storyline the cute
storyline and
uh so the more research we we did
there's so much research that when it
went into this show so max who's played
by shantae adams who is absolutely
incredible
is based on she's inspired by three
women tony stone connie morgan and mamie
johnson who went on to play in the negro
leagues with men and i knew about tony a
little bit when will asked me but these
are stories this is a big part of
american baseball history and i don't
think a lot of people know about it and
it was so i mean
i love that character so much and you
got to speak to some of these former
players right what was that like
pretty incredible i mean this film was
so important to me as a kid to see women
playing professional sports they're
still not
a professional baseball women's baseball
team and uh
or there has not been since this league
and so to get to talk to some of the
women who played in the all-american
girls professional baseball league and
some women who played softball uh around
the same time it's pretty priceless when
you're making a show like this well your
swing looks really good as as tony he
gave you a what grade did you give her a
plus
look at you
had you played before did you guys have
to take lessons how did that work i
played softball as a kid and my dad was
and i have an older brother and so i
played with them and so all the cast
came in with different skill levels very
different so
were there conversations like we really
liked so and so for the part but she
can't really throw well shantae is gonna
kill me who plays max who plays max but
in her i mean shantae is incredible and
the acting will always sort of override
of course i hear a butt coming and
they're stunt doubles and they're
stunned doubles i have a sun double as
well but shantae jeff
i fully lied i was like yeah i
definitely i played i played softball as
a kid and shantae was an incredible
cheerleader everybody did great abby
congratulations on this congratulations
on your engagement yep our best to go
nice to have you you can watch league of
their own now on prime video coming up
next a look at all that mattered this
week we'll be right back